right go ahead
um this was reported by the national
um
uh is reported by Sky News by which one
of the national
um statistics on the in the UK so the
rate of marriages between men and women
felt her record low in 2019 according to
figures from the office of national
statistics there were 18.6 marriages per
1000 unmarried men please and 17.2 per
1000 unmarried women the lowest records
since it began in 1862 a total of
213
122 heterosexual couples tied the knot
in 2019 which is down 50 percent since
its peak in 1972 and the lowest since
1888.
people ain't getting married now
like people people don't even believe in
marriage and going back to what I said
earlier on as marriage being a joke
the people don't care about it
yeah but why would my so before listen
look before we had to fight we had to
fight slay dragons man we have to go you
know like we had to all it took was the
you know she would just drop play
dragons no but no no the dragons at no
but essentially we have to deal me and
you on on God like right okay for the
woman like we were going the dad would
send us on the quest like this is what
traditionally what men will go and do
just for the smell of a woman and the
virgin woman right now men don't have to
do that men just need a nice car if that
a rental and tender men just need a good
profile picture this got and then
essentially the standard has been
dropped so soon so women control the
standard if they required marriage in
order for us to have sex I think the
standard really has dropped though of
course it has I don't think so I think
women have higher standards than ever no
they have average men used to be able to
get average women they can't anymore
where it's it's for a small percentage
of men sure standards have dropped it
but for every other man standards are
definitely higher I think I think
women's expectations of Ohio but their
standards have dropped so the
expectations of what they want standards
for themselves yeah but they don't they
don't settle 50 they're predicting that
50 of women will be single and childless
between the ages of 25 and 45. no they
don't settle off the chat and Tyrone
because they get mad so they don't
understand what the level is so that's
so but it's because the expectations are
so high if they actually was more
realistic about it they'll get better
results as long as you keep wanting the
same as long as 100 of women keep one of
the 20 20 of guys you're gonna still be
getting the bad results because it's the
expectation versus actually what your
real reality is Right women have always
wanted the 20 of guys always the
difference is now they have the option
not to do it
no but I've got a difference now is
hypergamies on steroids right now yeah
yeah but then you're going to get to the
point of where where you're gonna you're
gonna do all this for your 20s and if
you don't cash out if you don't select a
guy you're gonna get in your 30s and
then you're going to be competing with
the women in the 22s that don't mind
actually having a guy with a kid so now
automatically you're on your 30 saying I
don't want a guy with a kid then you've
got a girl that's in 22. I agree with
you I said she doesn't mind I agree with
you but my point is that like I think
standards are higher than ever before
and that's why like that's why there's
so many shows based off of this [ __ ]
because you think in 1950 that the women
there were saying six feet six figures
six inches no they want to marry Joe Joe
down the block
he's got a secure job it's harder than
ever for men to get sex the small
percentage of men sure
sure the the good-looking men over six
foot with good job sure it's crazy for
that most met like life is hard for most
men okay let's remove myself out of this
for a second so we'll remove ourselves
out because I'm thinking it from my
perspective right
but I would still say that that
expectations are higher and maybe their
standards are raised but what are you
what are your reality what do you get in
re in the real world your results and
the results don't match the expectations
or the standards that they play I've
always said that to him and I've said do
your do your expectations match your
results you said you want that guy that
that that that XYZ I'm like okay but do
your results match that and a lot of the
time they don't but they still want it
and which is why so many women as they
get older become are still single and
become in my personal point of view
bitter because they started making
expectations for themselves and
standards for themselves that they
wouldn't that that were never realistic
in the first place uh sorry I have a
question would you ever get married
oh in this current
this current version of marriage no
I I'm not gonna lie in this current the
way it's so heavily skewed towards women
I couldn't see myself what version of
marriage could you see I just told you
man I got a whole contract though no I'm
just saying like it would have to be
like I'm part of the car and that's what
I'm saying it's because of the you would
be with a woman long term though oh of
course
100 and you would love her right I
wouldn't be very devoted and committed
right no but you probably would have a
hard time signing the contract because a
contract a contract does not favor me
and so I believe in love I believe in
companionship I believe it meant that
the union between men and women I
believe in all of that but that contract
that you asked me to sign up like the
problem is what are guys like you
supposed to do sure sure maybe maybe you
had a good experience of marriage in
your family but that's not everyone like
some people watch their dad get taken to
the cleaners right some some men have
like watched their dad commit suicide
some some men thought that their their
dad was a deadbeat just to find out he
wasn't allowed in their life after 20
years and so it's like what are those
guys supposed to do the sign the same
contract they watched everyone else get
wrecked by I was in a 10-year
relationship
and it doesn't mean he doesn't love the
girl could have been classes of marriage
but even after going through that and
having the the isms and the schisms that
happen after that when you've got a
child with somebody etc etc I was like
imagine if I was married like I'm having
these problems without being married
imagine if I was married I'm curious how
long was it until the problem started
coming what would you say how many years
I would say six years in six years in I
would say about six years in would you
would you say there was like a switch
that was flipped or what did it did you
see signs early on I would say that I
could say looking back hindsight's 2020.
I would like ah you missed that yeah you
missed that oh you missed that didn't
you but because there's a whole thing of
when you're in a relationship you're
just in one and people from the outside
can see it which is very interesting
about love people from the outside can
say yeah I saw some things and you're
like no I love them I'm cool
everything's fine and that's what and
the thing is that's what essentially
what people are supposed to do in
relationships are not supposed to allow
people from the outside into there I
don't believe in allowing outside people
into your relationship
I don't believe that because I believe
that's one of the best ways for a
relationship to break down
so when you're in the relationship I get
why people say oh we were just in it and
it was happening and I didn't listen to
anybody else because I am I am a firm
believer that if I'm with you and you're
with me we should only listen to each
other because we are the ones in the
relationship no one else is in it it's
just us so I'm curious though don't you
think it you would have seen it sooner
had you listened to other people I would
have seen it sooner if I had educated
myself better
that like I I can take full
responsibility and say there were
certain things that I did not know when
I ended that relationship there are
things that now I know after being out
of the relationship and so for me it's
it's growth as a human being it's like
sometimes you you do you have to grow
you have to go through certain
situations to understand exactly what it
is so I would say
because the reason why I would say no
because even my I'm a stubborn
individual I know that about myself it's
if somebody from the outside is telling
me you can't do or you shouldn't do I'm
like [ __ ] you imma do it like I know
that about myself so I have to look I
know that I have to learn the hard way
that's just me it's an individual but
once I learn I'm like you're not gonna
fool me again I'm not gonna go through
that again because I am also a learner
so yeah
um if somebody from the outside could
have seen it would have been great if
they told me I probably still wouldn't
listen because I'm a hard-headed
individual so this is one of the
comments the reason it's six to seven
years is that's about how long women can
quote unquote live a lie before they
have to unburden themselves with the
torture of the lie that they don't
actually want the man they're with
probably that's what they said the thing
is the things that I've learned as a man
and being in a relationship like that
for me are they're priceless
for me I'm just saying for me that that
absolutely Priceless would you do it
again hell no like I wouldn't because
I'm smarter now that's the thing I like
I'm smarter now so I've learned from the
mistakes that I made and and I've always
said
the only way a man becomes I say the
only way one of the ways that men become
men is going through tough times is
going through things that we don't think
we're going to go through and we think
we're invincible and then life says haha
[ __ ] you [ __ ] here you go here's
a curveball right and I think that tough
time to produce tough people
I think easy times produce soft people
so I would say that any man that's gone
through something tough in his life
he's probably like a man that people
would want to be around and and he's
speaking like that because he's gone
through those things
this is on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible